hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute im hintergrund seht
ihr luca sitzen und ihr seht lukas pizza
wir machen nämlich heute ein video in
dem luca und ich gegeneinander antreten
wir sind gerade eben schon auf seinem
kanal angetreten vielleicht kommt ja
auch von daher weiß haben die aus
jerusalem bleibt man sieht hier leute
wir schnappen uns gleich schnäppchen und
werden mit steht dem gucken wer
schneller eine lupe zu essen kann also
ohne messer ohne alles die ist
ungeschnitten und der gewinner ist der
gewinner des lebens meine marke von 50
richtig nah an die presse ist war von
unangenehm
warum weiß ich gar nicht wo ist die
pizzen wir brauchen job des slk 2 so
leute jetzt sitzen wir hier haben unsere
steht am start haben unsere pizza am
start
auch wenn noch so aussieht ist es kein
werbe video auch wenn ich es gerne hätte
luca hat mir leider kein geld im spiel
dieses video oben macht schon über die
taktiken
wir fangen wir mal anzufügen sind
spieler dabei hardrock musik im
hintergrund alles klar
servus es übertrieben bei dem
taschengeld ist echt ganz aus der zeit
ihrer machen
der verlierer darauf eine dienstag
vollen kosten jeweils anderen einfach
mal wenn ich sag mal du verdient junge
warum das so ist und wie es geht
santa programm
die nato war hatte ich nicht so richtig
genießen was hat es mit stäbchen zu
zukünftigen zusammenführt so gut dass
oettingers tagen gegessen haben
werte wie du angst dass ich es nicht
schaffe ich das auch machen sage dass es
der welt gar nicht
doch seinen stücken um das schon fast
gehalten so bei zwei dritteln vom konsum
ersetzt das ich darf meine apps
verwenden man kann das ja auch nicht so
gut kommentieren neben beethoven
mittelfranken
das geht voll klar am tor vorbei jetzt
tritt der boxer wenn wir so machen
können
ich hatte den ball gut danke
[Musik]
hmm ich habe dich vor wulff gelegen
hatte der amokläufer wird man schon
nicht mehr so gut kommt ja leute dann
habe ich mir nach ich gesagt habe der
attentäter mit städtischen schachbezirk
[Musik]
pause
max ist deswegen jetzt schon ein
bisschen weiter essen ja nur meine leute
beim video die plaste jetzt gegessen
gerade keine ahnung verrichten
er hat mit dem ua die story nicht klappt
sowieso einschusslöcher mit tram oder
korn gewinnen ich habe den kommentare
kram an den hängen kraft ist ein
vollprofi und hätten den kopf ineinander
das wird recht machen
das ist echt viele leute die pizza 30 cm
durchmesser der kampf noch regel nur
ausgewählte zutaten
[Applaus]
das wurde jetzt ein paket kanal jetzt
mannschaft an doch genauso gut kann
abonnieren ja ich war spesen nicht was
er immer wollte seht ihr schon mal kurz
zum kopf-an-kopf-rennen kopf an kopf
drin
32 sie bleibt für george egloff video
noch einen kleinen video von mir so
pizza also ich bin großer fan von
petermann geriet also wenn ich irgendwie
pizza essen bestellen doch tatsächlich
eine pizza margherita deshalb würde ich
mich als margherita experte bezeichnen
und ich muss sagen ich war echt geil
also auch wenn du mein freund ist und
das wissen wir alle aber keine freunde
die pizza schmeckt so scheiße leute
kaufen
die pizzas so ruhen die pizza zum
gewissen alter und lassen leiter